alors on va passer du passé à annie
ernaux et qui a peut-être fait peut-être
je sais pas le contraire parce qu'elle
fait ainsi alors avant de dire ce qui a
nourri j'aurais dire la manière parce
que évidemment c'est très important
extrait de la page 24
depuis peu je sais que le roman est
impossible pour rendre compte d'une vie
soumise à la nécessité c'est bien celle
de votre père je n'ai pas le droit de
prendre d'abord le parti de l'art et de
chercher à faire quelque chose de
passionnant où des mouvements entre
guillemets je rassemblerai les paroles
et gestes les goûts de mon père les
faits marquants de sa vie
tous les signes objective une existence
que j'ai aussi partagez aucune poésie du
souvenir pas de dérision jubilante
l'écriture plate me vient naturellement
celle là même que j'utilisais en
écrivant autrefois mes parents pour leur
dire les nouvelles essentielles
oui je crois que c'était très important
pour moi de ne pas vouloir faire un
roman avec l'existence de mon père se
met apparu comme une sorte de trahison
bien parce que quand on fait un roman
d'abord on prend un personnage ce
personnage souhaité mon père j'aurais
j'aurais fait son portrait j'aurais
parler de lui très certainement soit en
en embellissant vraisemblablement en
embellissant beaucoup de choses et aussi
en faisant des scènes comme si j'y étais
encore par exemple en feront traces en
produisant un paysage à toutes sortes de
choses qui ne paraissait pas du tout
rendre sa vie la vie de mon père est une
existence qui était vraiment très très
pauvre départ il a quitté l'école à 12
ans pour aller travailler dans une ferme
parce qu'on avait besoin qu'il travaille
dans une ferme et on voyait pas d'autre
possibilité
et ensuite il y est resté jusqu au
régiment ensuite et bien il est devenu
ouvrier
c'était toujours ce que j'appelle la
nécessité il n'y avait pas d'autre choix
et après les découvreurs enfin la fait
divers travaux manuels
enfin il s'est marié avec sa femme ma
mère il a pris un petit commerce qui
était vraiment très petit en normandie
il ne pouvait absolument pas vivre sur
ce commerce tous les deux et il est
resté ouvriers jusqu'à la guerre 40
ensuite il s'est établi en fin de la
guerre et en 45 il a pu avoir un
commerce un café épicerie qui le laisser
vivre
donc c'était une vie qui a été toujours
vraiment c'est une toute petite
ascension sociale
une vie où là il y avait beaucoup de
jeunes
sylvie que j'ai partagé et avec ça on
peut pas faire deux romans je crois que
pour retrouver il fallait que je que je
scrute vraiment dans ma mémoire toutes
les choses qui m'avait marqué travailler
sur la mémoire travaille aussi beaucoup
sur tout ce que j'avais entendu est
enfant je pense que les mots les phrases
qu'on emploie retrait ce vraiment le
monde où l'on vive par exemple très
souvent on disait la maison on n'est pas
malheureux il y a plus malheureux que
nous oui il ya rien que de dire cela se
montre très montre a déjà notre
limitation enfin tous heures de phrases
qui m'ont beaucoup marqué on me disait
ah moi d'une compte rien d'une compte
c'était vraiment c'est une fille ou tout
coûter cher où on était extrêmement
limité et je pense que l'église le roman
le livre de souvenirs aussi
ça c'est pas du tout une critique pour
emmanuel clancier mais ça embellit
toujours c'est au regard des souvenirs
quand on quand on se laisse aller et moi
je ne voulais pas me laisser aller je
voulais à travers l'histoire de mon père
surtout c'est je pense que c'est aussi
la mémoire de beaucoup d'autres gens que
je rattrape oui mais alors quitte à vous
déplaire je vous dire que votre livre il
est beau il est émouvant et que cette
simplicité cette extrême simplicité
enlève dollars seulement contradictoire
c'est ce que nous a dit parce que vous
avez vous vous insurgez contrôle arrêt
vous avez fait de l'art et bien vous
n'avez peut-être pas fabulé vous n'avez
pas extrapoler vous ai choisis les seuls
mots capables de rendre ce que vous
dites
avec d'ailleurs un professionnalisme
tout à fait extraordinaire et qui est un
peu le contraire de ce que vous dites
oui oui je pense que c'est à dire c'est
le pointu roman peut-être traditionnels
que j'ai refusé j'ai voulu d'abord je
voulais vraiment faire une commande
d'écriture plate dont vous avez parlé
l'écriture du constat c'est à dire je ne
voulais pas commenté sa soeur joue enfin
des préoccupations très importante
commenté par exemple eh bien mon grand
père mon grand père qui ne savaient pas
lire non plus et qui a fini sa vie à
l'hôpital
eh bien mon père allait lui porte et
c'est pas la peine de lui porter des
choses culturelles parce qu'ils ne
savaient pas lire et bien vu portait son
petit verre son petit flacon de gouttes
disait la goutte
viens je n'ai pas à commenter jeudi les
faits tels qu'ils sont il me semble que
ça suffit et voilà tout ne voulait pas
non plus raconté ce qu'il ya autour
voulait pas dire voilà ce qu'on chantait
à cette époque sauf une
et puis il ya le effectivement et c'est
pour ça qu'il restait un livre très très
court qui fait 500 petites pages et
cette simplicité mais la chute dans les
mosquées yaro fut de l'air qui débouche
quand même sur assure un art tout à fait
est patent ce que je crois moi ce qui me
semble
vous êtes extrêmement sensible à votre
livre c'est que vous parlez en effet
d'écriture du constat mais le sentiment
que j'ai c'est en effet qu' il y avait
un tel amour en vous en deçà de votre
écriture et une telle émotion que le
contrôle et que presque malgré vous dire
est justement cette émotion et la
triforce est très fort et ce n'est pas
fini si c'est en apparence une écriture
de constats et ce n'est pas une
clairière constat mais je dresse un
portrait été tenus mais très tendue à la
phrase qui me une phrase qui est
terrible et cruellement
j'écris peut-être parce qu'on n'avait
plus rien à se dire oui je crois que oui
c'est vrai c'est parce que mon père ne
savait pas parler
le beau langage le langage des classes
dominantes
il parlait encore un peu patois et et il
y à désirer par dessus tout c'est que je
fasse des études que j'ai des diplômes
que j'ai tout ce qu'il n'avait pas eu
et au fur et à mesure que j'obtenais ses
diplômes que je en même temps moi je
changeais de monde et je n'ai pas été
une enfant double j'étais une enfant
déchiré je pense déchirée entre le
milieu mes parents et puis un milieu
petit bourgeois que automatiquement je
me suis mise à fréquenter et j'avais des
indices et j'avais des intérêts
différents des siens je lisais on se
comprend me parlait plus le même langage
je crois que cette question de langage
entre lui et moi et c'était extrêmement
puis dit que c'était peut-être la chose
fut terrible oui mais en même temps il
n'aimait pas que que vous dites par
exemple
[Musique]
je suis pas prof ou bien bouquin il
n'aimait pas ça non parce qu'ils aient
pensé que si j'avais eu la chance
d'apprendre justement a bien parlé
c'était manqué de respect finalement à
ce que ce qu'on apprenait il avait un
respect très religieux de l'école met
d'ailleurs vous aussi vous dit que le
problème de langage était important
d'endroits que c'est capital
ce sont les mêmes problèmes posent les
mêmes effets humains et ils parlaient
entre eux à toi ou du pape ait parlé
limousin entre mes grands parents mes
automatiquement lorsqu'il s'adressait à
moi il me parlait français et il
attendait que je ne les y vivent pas
mais que je parle français justement
parce que ça leur pari c'est une sorte
de promotion nécessaire vers yves est
certainement d'un autre monde dit ça
d'une manière il souffrait en effet de
se sentir comme relégué dans ce monde
qui les aimait pourtant profondément
oui oui mais et c'est là où ça devient
passionnant votre ville c'est que donc
vous vous avez des diplômes ou devenez
quelqu'un d'instruit et plus il reste ce
qu'il est il est fier de sa fille mais
en même temps il y en a un peu honte
parce que vous dites ceci dans la
famille les clients de la gêne presque
de la honte que je gagne que je ne gagne
pas encore ma vie à 17 ans alors
qu'autour de lui que les filles il
craignait qu'on ne me prenne pour une
paresseuse et lui pour un crâne heures
comme une excuse on ne l'a jamais poussé
à la baisse alors très très nettes c'est
à dire que pour lui le travail le
travail du chapeau au travail de la tête
comme il disait
eh bien c'était pas ça n'a jamais au
fond était un vrai travail je pense que
je pense que beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent de leur main continue de le
penser parce que on peut pas tricher
quand on travaille de ses mains et que
la tête ça lui paraissait travail avec
sa tête parce je repense et de ses
expressions qu'il avait très souvent
c'était c'était à la fois et il pensait
que c'était pas facile non mais que
c'était un peut-être un jeu que c'était
ça n'était simple gêne aussi dure et de
quand il en paye mon travail il me
disait jamais te travaille bien à
l'école il es tu apprends bien parce que
pour lui travailler c'est nage toujours
été trouvés ces malheurs et me voyais
continue des études et vis-à-vis des
autres d autres des clients qui pour la
plupart étaient des ouvriers et il
pensait que finalement j'avais bien de
la chance qu'il ne fallait pas fallait
pas écraser de cette chance que je
l'avais ton entourage
et puis en même temps vous si vous le
dites d'un livre vous trouvez vous le
citez ce mot paix que nous a fait un peu
péquenots de ce que vous aimiez et
quelques années auparavant
vous vous en détourner oui c'est à dire
qu'il ya une coupure qui passe par mois
cette année aucun passe en moi j'aimais
tout ce qui est mais mes parents c'est à
dire manger mais j'aimais aussi bien
lire confidences j'aimais lire les
feuilletons tout ça me plaisait et un
moment par par l'école g on m'a appris
que c'était delahaye était bon tout ça
c'était péquenots et est donc je suis ce
jeu me tester paris moi même en tant que
j'ai été séparé de mes parents c'est
comme ça c'est c'est les effets de ces
effets de la sortie de l'ascenseur
social qu'il ya dans tout en fin de
rencontre un peu partout il ya un ancien
mois et un nouveau mois et je crois que
c'est de la faute s'était mis à [ __ ]
de mes parents je pas dire c'était ma
faute mais enfin c'est comme ça et avec
celui vous vous rembourser une dette une
réparation sûrement une réparation si
aussi le désir de faire vivre la culture
de mon père dire
ce qu'il est mais je décris comment il
tenait ses mains comment ils pas cessé
dimanche et que tout cela c'est pas
méprisable
c'est aussi réhabiliter son mode de vie
à lui